[Music]
can oppression help produce masterpieces
do we need rules and constraints to fuel
our creativity or should ever greater
freedom be our continuing goal now
joining me to discuss our loki aka Karim
Daniels he's a British Iraqi hip-hop
artist and activist Janet cavanna is the
winner of the orange first Nobel Prize
Janna's works include a field guide to
reality the ice Museum and in glorious
and remotion at the end there is
professor of arts at John Hopkins
University and Andrew you were the the
UK poet laureates for ten years and
you're also the author of coming into
land and Philip Larkin a writer's life
so our opening question and I'm gonna
put it to you first slow key is freedom
vital for creativity to flourish
okay so firstly what's interesting about
this is we're being asked to think on a
premise that oppression or constraint
leads to better art so now what I want
to argue is that there is a worst-case
scenario of this conclusion and a
best-case scenario of this conclusion
the best-case scenario of this
conclusion that oppression creates
somehow greater or more beautiful works
is in its absolute best what it acts to
do within our minds is to make more
tolerable repression and violence
against thinkers who go outside of the
norm and that it's very worst what it
does is it credits the brilliance of
people rather than to the people that
produce those works but to the people
that oppress them so if I can make it
more simple for you it's the equivalent
of us saying that Galileo's work on the
laws of physics were thanks to Pope
Urban because he put him under house
arrest and put him in the position where
that happened it's the equivalent of us
saying that urban and Haytham x'
development of the idea that the ancient
Greeks had is their conviction that
light was shot out by the eyes and
that's what enabled people to see
so even and Haytham when put under house
arrest by the Fatimid caliph s-- at that
time because of being under house arrest
and having a hole in the wall he was
able to fashion that into an
understanding that in fact what happens
is light reflects off of objects and
therefore the eye sees so what we're in
danger of doing is crediting the people
that tighten the constraints with the
brilliance of the people who despite
their circumstances are able to make
great leaps for Humanity
so the question also is is that would
these people if they enjoyed state
patronage rather than state restriction
not come out with equally if not more
amazing ideas we see from history
examples of people like Victor Jara in
Chile for example during the Salvador
Allende government democratically
elected government he was patronized by
the state he enjoyed state sponsorship
the music he created was beautiful and
spoke to and for millions however
following the coup on September 11th
1973 backed by the British and US
government and the introduction of
General Pinochet as the ruler of Chile
Victor Jara was imprisoned in Chile
Stadium a long five along with 5,000
other people during his torture he
actually set about writing his last song
which was called Chile Stadium it was an
unfinished work which was smuggled out
of the stadium by a friend of his who
put it into his sock this is a perfect
example of state repression leading to
somebody actually dying so this idea of
oppression creating great work we also
see the the work that he created was
actually unfinished so it's very easy
for us to sometimes philosophize about
situations we have not lived through and
pontificate about the possibility that
oppression or state restriction somehow
leads to greater art so I would say that
is my position on this
down there let me ask you Johanna is
freedom vital for creativity to flourish
reminds a bit of the old some is that
joke you know yeah I'm totally free
you know I'm free to write my work
myself I'm free to edit it myself free
to publish it myself free to go to jail
myself you know I mean this idea of
freedom is obviously totally fundamental
something I'm going to agree a lot with
what Loki said actually original work in
whatever discipline we're you know
defining it whether we're talking about
originality in science as Loki's
mentioned or in art and music poetry
prose it fundamentally requires a
pushing at the limits all the time of
what is known and what is acceptable and
what is tasteful and decorous and it
won't be original and innovative and
exciting if it isn't fundamentally doing
that so it may clash with precepts and
conventions of course and that the
artist and the creative person needs
that freedom and if they're constantly
anticipating some kind of control or
censorship as a result what they're
doing in the privacy of their own
creative realm then they won't be free
as they do that of course that that
external pressure will come into the
creative process and so there's that
point about the creator but there's also
the point about the audience you know
you don't create in a vacuum ideally so
any form of censorship or control of
what can be said or created implies that
someone's going to stand between the
creator and the audience and they make
the decision for the audience about what
the audience can know and see and hear
and who will do that who will be the
censor who amongst us today would like
to take that role will stand and say I
will decide what each one of us here is
going to know about the world so there's
a crucial point in censorship about
knowledge but I think in a free society
we have the right to know as well what's
being said and thought so and I don't
agree with the notion the depression
causes great arts so unrushed he said
it's a bit like saying it's so wonderful
that man lost both his arms because now
he paints so beautifully with the pet
you know the paintbrush in his mouth
you know it's a it's an invidious notion
of course and try telling that to garcia
lorca he was murdered by Franco's thugs
or Radcliffe Hall his work was totally
silenced because she wrote about love
between women try telling it to AI
weiwei who's been forced out of his own
country and lost you know any contact
day by day with his mother and his wife
you know try telling that to them that
the the pressure therefore means that
you are the censored and that's what
you're the silenced and your work is
assessed on that premise as well so all
people talk about is that your work is
censored and that's what's happened to
it
so this actually brings me this idea of
silencing so it's not entirely the same
as what we're talking about with formal
constraints and there's a question
within the rubric about constraints and
restraints as a formal suggestion that
doesn't necessarily oppress Shakespeare
wrote five act plays poets use stanzas
and form and you know musicians use
musical forms and I write novels that's
a tote that is a different thing but it
you may have a kind of ideologue like
Stalin who just likes realism and stops
people like the Russian absurdists from
writing fantasy and imposes a
restriction on a form that may be a form
of oppression but it's not necessarily
linked so I will end there arts an
opinion about the world it can be
completely transformative and it has to
be free and who has not been radically
inspired and transformed by works of
Arts even perhaps by those artists
who've been banned and censored by
Leonardo himself Michelangelo Voltaire D
H Lawrence Ratcliffe Hall Nadine
Gordimer Salman Rushdie Toni Morrison
Orhan Pamuk Solzhenitsyn Chan Khong Chun
you jabo I could continue alas Turgenev
said without freedom in the widest sense
of the world the artist is unthinkable
and Salman Rushdie said art is not
entertainment at its best it is a
revolution thanks thank you
you're quite invigorated by that Andrew
lastly you is freedom vital for
creativity to flourish the bad thing
about coming in a panel of three is that
a lot of things he want to say already
been said there's not a thing that's
been said that I miss you have to be
creative and the idea that you that art
thrives on the impression in a simple
ways clearly ridiculous and very well
said by lo Qian and also by John has a
social dimension too of course this it
would be like saying let's throw lots of
Christians to the Lions so that the
Church of England statistics look better
again and more people go to church I
mean clearly a ridiculous idea but what
I wanted to do is slightly different
perhaps with a bit more than thinking
about form which is something that we
can continue to think about in the next
few minutes but I wanted to start by
thinking about material circumstances
which is to say the degree of freedom is
necessary for creativity to exist a
degree of peace and quiet a degree of
provision space materials and possibly
but not necessarily at the point of
creation a sense of audience which
begins to be I think part of your point
in fact the sort of things that Virginia
Woolf talks about in a Room of One's Own
not even Solzhenitsyn and Mandelstam
could have written without a modicum of
these things and it's very noticeable if
you think about first world war poetry
that Wilfred Owen in Sassoon wrote their
best poems not at the front when they
were under fire oppression of a sort
it's not sort of narrowly political
oppression but of oppression of a sort
didn't tried their best friends at the
front they wrote their best poems when
they were back in the war hospital in
Craig Lockhart motivates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at AI TV
you